Andrew let's flip to your second
moonshot which is the idea of universal
basic income um so uh the idea just to
lay it out as I understand it and I
welcome your uh your modification here
is as Ai and Robotics and other
exponentials 3D printing arvr blockchain
start to disrupt the job markets and
people uh lose their jobs to technology
um
that we need to do a few things one of
them is going to be to help uh level up
those individuals upscale them to better
skills but potentially at least in the
interim is give them reliable income uh
a universal basic income that allows
them to you know put food on the table
get insurance um not feel panicked uh
perhaps get a better education perhaps
invest in whatever Tech they need to to
start a small business uh and it's about
human dignity to a large degree um and
getting rid of fear because there going
to be a lot of fear as AI steps in in a
bigger way in the next uh few years um
I'll say one more thing and then this is
your platform and you did a huge amount
to I want say necessarily popularize but
educate people about Universal basic
income which I'm I'm grateful for um the
other thing I want to to mention is uh
it is something that's not a
theoretical uh concept it's been
implemented and tested and uh and
studied uh over dozens if not hundreds
of experiments both in the United States
and around the world so that's my setup
for it and I want people to understand
it's uh this is coming because we need a
counterveiling force to the fear that
people have about potentially losing
their jobs well I I love the way you
frame that Peter the the way I describe
it is that you have a mindset of
abundance and possibility and optimism
and Entrepreneurship and then you have a
mindset of scarcity fear Us Versus Them
xenophobia uh uh and negativity towards
technology honestly and so which of
these things is winning which of these
is going to win um I think you'd be
hardpressed to say that Nationwide the
mindset of optimism and possibility is
winning it's definitely winning at
abundance 360 which was a blast like
over there and it's like I was uplifted
because here are people who are
literally building the the future but
then you know you drive a few hours in
any direction and you wind up like a
let's say a different mindset um and so
the the question is how do we help
people transition there are a lot of
very smart folks who are deep in AI
who've also been um studying the effects
of Ubi or cash relief programs and one
of the things I think is going to appeal
to folks uh like you is that right now
we have the worst of all worlds where
we're spending so much money and energy
on dysfunctional administration of
programs that are really punitive and
dehumanizing I spoke to thousands of
Americans who are on various Aid
programs and the single biggest thing
that motivates them is fear they are
scared stiff of losing their benefits
there was a woman in Iowa who said to me
uh I would like to volunteer for my
local nonprofit but I'm scared to
because I'm on disability and I'm afraid
that if someone saw that I could
volunteer they'd take my money away yeah
and so you listen to that story and you
think my gosh like what have we done
where This Woman's getting the money but
instead of using the money to live a
better life she's staying in because
she's afraid of being seen as
able-bodied I mean like that that's
what's happening right now for millions
and millions of Americans where we've
set up this unfeeling machine above them
that they do not trust at all by the way
and said hey your uh subsistence is
going to be relying upon your staying on
the good side of this bureaucracy and if
you fill out the form wrong we're going
to pull a rug out from under you I mean
like I I i' I've spoken to military vets
who are in this boat I've spoken to so
many americ Americans and it it's uh we
can do better let's say yeah jelle sent
me an article uh which framed it as
insecurity versus uh inequality as the
issue people are facing they don't feel
secure they do not feel secure in the in
the least and if we can change that then
we have a much better chance of building
uh Society where if someone else makes
some rapid Advance you look at it and
say oh good like May maybe that's good
for me in some way right now
unfortunately it's more like like look
at that jerk over there who's doing well
like you know um uh like I'm not seeing
any of that you've studied this um if
you had to uh you know most people say
listen if you're sending people 500
bucks a month it's going to be used for
beer and Netflix and it's a waste of
money for God's sakes why are you going
to spend my tax money to do that uh how
do you respond to that what's the dat
show well the the the data shows that
people tend to spend the money
on uh food fuel shelter books for their
kids uh activities for their kids uh and
the biggest example of that data set was
the enhanced child tax credit that was
implemented in 2020 and
2021 yeah in the US where it lifted
millions of American kids out of poverty
and 130 economists who looked at it said
we should keep doing this because the
money is getting used very very
effectively uh and uh American politics
being what it is we then pulled the plug
on that even though there were so many
uh literally there were Nobel laurates
saying this is the best thing we've done
in a generation to alleviate poverty U
but the data is there for anyone to find
um you also saw saw saw decreases in
things like domestic violence child
abuse uh I mean if you put a little bit
of money into people's hands you talked
about the data Peter there was one study
I found very very compelling out of an
Indian tribe in North Carolina where One
Tribe started uh giving people a certain
amount of money because they had a
casino honestly and then there was
another tribe that I've got it here it's
the Eastern uh band of Cherokee Indians
Casino dividend in North
Carolina uh and giving them no strings
attached between 4,000 and 6,000 per
year is that particular one and what and
you probably have it there that um you
had the kids uh learn better and their
even their personalities became U more
conscientious more trusting they en
education mental health decrease in
addiction and crime yeah yeah and by the
way if you wound up with people who do
turn to crime and drugs we end up paying
for that too in ways big and small I
mean like that we're spending 30 to
$50,000 per individual per year who is
homeless or incarcerated uh in our
country so if it hits our institutions
it's a lot more expensive than that $4
and $6,000 that those uh kids got yeah
lest you think that this is a a new idea
I'm just going to Rattle off here the
research that my producer Nick did you
know um we've seen this in Alaska since
1982 uh Alaska's had uh their their fund
funded by by oil I mentioned North
Carolina we've had experiments in New
Jersey uh Pennsylvania Iowa North
Carolina Seattle Denver Gary Indiana a
number is a big study done in Stockton
uh California uh Canada uh England
Brazil Germany Spain the Netherlands has
done a number
Finland uh Iran Kenya uh Namibia India
China um so I mean this has been done
hundreds of times and as I read through
the details here it's
consistent that this investment has
super positive outcomes I haven't read
any place where it's been had negative
outcomes or waste of money yeah it it's
much more effective than frankly um
starting up a new bureaucracy and then
saying hey guys uh improve the lives of
people that are not you um one of the
organizations in the space that some
people might have heard of is give
directly which is it transfers money
directly to people in developing
countries uh now there's probably some
skepticism among your audience uh
rightly so of kind of a nonprofit
industrial complex or an NGO industrial
complex um there's probably that
mistrust when it comes to certain
government bureaucracies that are
terrible at uh administering benefits in
a like a frankly a sane way this skips
the middleman uh and gets the resources
to where it'll actually do good yeah and
I i' I've been a donor to give directly
I think it's a uh it's a brilliant uh
you know super low overhead um minimized
overhead U process on a personal level
Peter the way that you and I do this
probably is we just tip really well uh
you know because you're around someone
it's like hey this is going to be dollar
for
dollar and it's such a beautiful thing
when when someone unexpectedly gets a a
large tip and you know for that evening
that moment you've changed their life
yeah it's a great great feeling I highly
recommend it yeah yeah uh so the
question becomes where does this money
come from uh you know can we afford it
and I'd like to play a few a few
conversational games here you know I
remember Jeff Bezos and a few other
folks said well if we're going to start
to see technological displacement of
jobs and a robot takes you know a house
cleaning job or a robot takes a factory
working job or an AI takes a physician's
job why don't we just tax that robot and
that AI uh for that work it's being done
and then use that tax base to fund a Ubi
program does that make sense I think
taxing AI makes a lot of sense uh I
think um the practice of it might be a
little bit
trickier uh the where the money comes
from for starters I I don't know what
people are going to receive this so our
data right now is is worth hundreds of
billions of dollars a year um to various
companies your data is going to be worth
more than others
Peter thanks um but we're not seeing a
dime of that so uh one of the proposals
I had was look there should be a data
dividend where I'm not one to hold back
uh certain forms of development but if
you're going to be buying and selling my
data uh maybe I should see what's going
on and get a cut and you know and and
um that could be the start of multi
hundreds of billions of dollars uh type
measure uh AI itself um could also and
one of the examples I use is that there
are 2 million Americans who work at call
centers still and let's say that AI is
going to be able to do that job pretty
soon how much do those 2 million
Americans pay in taxes right now I'm
going to guess that they do pay taxes
and then the question is will the tech
company that use the AI pay anywhere
near that level in taxes history
suggests it will not um and so you'll
wind up replacing taxpaying humans with
AI that um we might not see that kind of
revenue from unless we change the
system hey YouTube glad you're enjoying
the podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank
you